blah blah excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
I feel so out of reach you always land
on your feet bro you're hymen
guys
but do not open it you went in to get us
jobs and all you brought back was the
hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
what the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
hey man
okay
foreign
[Music]
it's some kind of world destroying
weapons it's designed to protect its
host
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it doesn't
I I think I caught a bus in half
the Scarab chose you but it belongs to
me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
choice
whoa
whoa It's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
[Music]